[Music]
but now you know what I want to talk
about I want to talk about everything
sweet every anything and everything then
someone hit me with something let's talk
about it anything everything the game
everything every class last week or two
weeks ago for ps4 I played a good deal
amount of it last week I'm ps4 this is a
weird game we want to talk about what
kind of game it is and what you do in it
and what is going on I haven't played a
phone i understand though you can embody
anything and everybody much of the
Galactic level on the bit on the upper
tier or on the molecular level oh my god
don't embarrass ya look at that bear go
say that's how everything losing the
game um in your time did you find that
this expression is anything it does not
it didn't get old yet because I didn't
start in this in a tutorial area and you
go around so you don't always start the
same animal so I started as an oxen in
the desert and I was walking around
talking to rocks and palm trees and
little mesas and they were telling me
what was going on because I had no idea
yeah and they were just saying some some
of these haikus that were explaining
what was happening and then I was
hoarding up with other oxen and speeding
up as you can see they're doing here
with these black bears and some of them
and I know the answer what is the point
uh you know the answer good i know they
can tell me because I don't know I you
it's just exploring and kind of what is
the end objective you mean no what's the
point of it all Mike ah why would you
engage in this game just to explore and
be different things I mean look you can
be this is not to understand your place
in the universe I guess so yeah see
different perspectives how did you say
isn't asking what the point of this game
the point of this game exactly um also
the title is super weird for SEO like I
don't know hi how do you google ever
just everything game vs it's really
interesting i'm following this game for
a while when i first heard of it I was
like wait you can inhabit a coffee cup
you can inhabit a banana you can do
anything but I know there's like some
sound bites from
British philosopher whose name is
escaping a lot yes and I feel like that
would get really i don't like
heavy-handed stuff like that no no what
have you i have an encounter knee that
yet i look to a little bit of it in the
video coverage we have and he basically
starts going on it like UK you know we
look at animals as just animals right
but to them if you imagine what you know
how we consider ourselves human animals
think that they're human not like us but
an equivalent in their eyes and so it's
experiencing these perspectives of
everything that you know where anything
can literally feel like it's important
and have a place in the world and it
just depends on your scale and you know
perspective and location and all that so
i'm not too gone down to this molecular
level here i went up so the galaxy is
the highest you can go you can't go past
into like a what's after that like a
star cluster now star clusters in a
galaxy whatever you can't go to like a
universal level because they've been be
able to show that but eventually you
know you can be a continent you can be i
see land mass and then you can go across
the ocean come up to a desert land mass
and then you can go down into the
molecular level of that desert land mass
passing through camels and rocks and
mesas and palm trees and a lot of things
and i haven't inherited anything
man-made yet but this gameplay trailer
this is a game clincher are watching
from a playstation blog i believe a few
months ago you can like inhabit a
spaceship it looked like later on in
this and what by trailer i mean like
gameplay trailer bicycles would you say
life goals yeah you can it looks like
you could be a spaceship and then it's
funny when you're a plant you don't move
around is like a herd or anything you
actually just kind of grow in a line
like a new tree will pop up in a set
path and here you see this camel is kind
of in this weird deciduous forest
joining up with other camels with
strange markings and now you see an oak
tree and now you're prettier rose if
your continent can you cause an
earthquake i don't know like a tsunami
across the ocean yeah can you just like
really mess everything up I'm pretty
cool as long as I hurt anyone oh the
hearts actually signify anything or is
it just when
switch to something else no those are
when you when you're an animal you can
group up with other similar animals I
hear the land mass so you see it moving
across the ocean expanse unrealistic
yeah dang you can see this is running on
unreal fort nah just kidding um this
game is it was weird i think is I kind
of grouped it normal and Rob hammer he
brought this up after playing absolute
last year yeah or and I brought up the
flower or journey comparisons almost and
it's kind of meditative playing this
game right here you become a
life-supporting planet I mean I don't
they don't call it earth I don't believe
this does have like an auto play mode
right where you can just sort of let it
do its own thing oh I don't know I
didn't do that yeah they're uh Andrew
over at playstation andrew kelly he was
tweeting about that which sounds kind of
interesting like I almost might like to
have it on in my desk just act like this
weird by own thing going on next to me
Lou Drago and the YouTube chato said if
I wanted science I'll go and get a book
right there with you I have fun with air
green and YouTube's kind of got a good
point it's like it pretty much is kind
of like I am I am bread right except
you're just other stuff and you can just
keep changing to other stuff I mean like
there's obviously a little bit more
complexity to it but well they
definitely try to rope in like
philosophy is a big part of it I mean
that's the part that gives me pause like
that's the part I I liked least about
the witness for example and you like
have to start listening to all the
philosophy and I was like no I was
thinking my own philosophy owes having
my own thoughts I don't could tell you
handed yeah and so I think it's
interesting it's sort of like an art
installation i think is how gamespot's
review or described it but i think it's
it would be better left q you kind of
reflecting on in oh if it is about how
everything in the world is
interconnected then that's for you to
extrapolate from it I don't need
somebody to tell me that and I don't
need to have the philosophy fed to me
right you know actually telling and not
showing yeah I think that's what
disrupts the the cool Nate like the
interesting thing about it for me
because it's like oh you know I don't
think I would ever spend too much time
with this
but the if I spent you know 30 minutes
with it that time is valuable from what
I can't garlic cloves you can also just
be silly but yeah I don't know it it's
it's strange to me if you like
unfinished or something like an
unfinished thought mm-hmm my concern is
that because there's so much to be it's
overwhelming me in the sense that no
man's sky did at first I was like what's
the point of seeing anything if you
could see everything I don't know okay
here we go clearly some cooper made that
barrel and then you can transfer into a
lion that was the design choice to make
a move like that why wonder what's
behind that it's got to be just as a
joke or it in it I can only assume
otherwise that it's a means to just get
this game out that we're not meeting
legends yes I am growing just yeah what
on earth as a lion will for those just
joining this is the desert level from
call of duty to now this is everything
an odd game it's part of the the play
collective Sony's due in the spring with
that I don't like it's not like artistic
games only because rain world is a part
of it as well but certainly like offbeat
screams it's definitely experimental I
oh my gosh this is a dinner yes anymore
I need it that's another thing that's
weird to me is like if it is for comedic
effect like if it is sort of breaking
down traditional mechanics the way
something like like I am bread which
aaron Eric green in the YouTube chat
brought up it's weird it's at odds with
the more kind of reflective
introspective philosophical stuff and
that's what's weird to me yeah i think
but also like when your plants are when
they show those butterflies it looks
pretty beautiful the way they're moving
in these sperm cells here as you can see
i don't know what what else would you
call it or not summers oh my i know what
else you would call sperm cells saying
what else would those be here we go two
turtles I like those
[Laughter]
up you set it up and I you a looped me
on that one oh here we go so now we're
getting into more man-made what was that
art movie about the praça yonder Scott
home gym yeah yeah yeah I had to watch
that for an art writing class that I
took against my will I sure I mean what
do you mean sure I know you okay and it
was super about it like it starts off
showing these pastoral sublime kind of
landscapes and all of a sudden there's
farms cropping up and then all of a
sudden there's a city and then there's
the ocean halakazi as well no there's
like three movies in that series they're
all a bit much okay art school place is
cool I studied journalism okay here we
have lightning bugs and fish oh here we
go okay so there I have not gone to the
point where i was using man-made stuff I
don't know and there's a spaceship I
don't know if that's a one of the cases
where that's a matter of playing in like
a matter of time in the game where the
game itself progressives or if I could
go do that right now if I take the right
path through the right number of item on
what this looks normal this looks like
an I Spy book oh the barrel I base oh no
is he okay is he okay oh I don't like
him hypno telling amer with a violin
that's sick oh this is pretty cool I
haven't seen anything like this before
here I see you that's on things did
universe deteriorate in this game
there's time sped up this is I have no
no this is new to all of us at once and
you know like i said the LME comes sold
separately yeah so the playstation could
not supply that for you unfortunately i
don't know what kind of music would
accompany this well i mean they have
ambient music but what kind of music
would you play for that ragtime Motown
so that would be weird that game is
weird no the question I want to ask is
what kind of game is this and I'm more
confused now than I want the beginning
of the segment it's a yeah I don't know
the introspective game I mean it's
experimental and it's no it's about
exploration more than it is anything
includes the central congruent just like
doing what you
you like doing follow your heart yeah on
Twitter jobo underscore GMS is the
concept of everything enough to sustain
interest for longer play durations
that's kind of what I was wondering i
don't think i would play this game long
for the same reason playing a lot of
persona 5 it would it's I'm not feeling
rewarded for it again it's more
meditative for me and it's kind of just
seeing what will happen yeah I mean not
every game has to be something you'll
spend a lot of time with him in some of
my favorite games are games that i spent
you know an hour with and i was one and
done and then I was like that was so
cool and it made me really think about a
lot of things and I mean I think this
has the potential to do that but it's I
don't know it's a little too abstract
for me I'm kind of like I I don't know
what I'm supposed to be getting out of
this besides being like whoa molecules
are so small I feel like more than most
games you have to be in the right
mindset to play it and you get something
out of it yeah ok this game seems right
up your alley yeah is there a third gear
to farm yeah you can use in Madison
flowers the universe is the the truest
mm oh no i don't think i can say
anything more profound than that I kind
of I don't know if i'll play more this
game i want to but i also have a lot of
other games to play and again I feel
like I saw everything but I know I
didn't but I kind of want to get to the
poem and having these artificial things
these ships these spaceships vessels
anyway okay thank you there anyway let
us know if you plan on playing us amid
all the other releases this is available
on PlayStation that leaves coming to pc
soon sure okay you tell me I don't know
it is coming to pc soon and you can
check it out on that let us know what
you think about everything
[Music]
you